Rob's World!
Hey, what's up guys?! It's Rob and welcome to my tutorial for the Mini Magic Ball.
The magic Balls are sometimes
called Dragons Eggs because of the way
they look. and I think and I think they're some of the coolest Origami Toys out there!
Based upon the classic water-bomb base, the Magic Balls, the Origami Magic balls were created by Yuri and Katrin Shumakov
It's called the mini magic ball because it has a lot
fewer folds than the regular one that I have here
*It's a great stress reliever
that you can squish, compress like this
into a flower and stretch it out and
then you could turn it on to the other
side flip it inside out and do the same
providing hours of fun! Since the
majority of people in my ninja star cube
video and over 90 percent of people in
my time lapse video wanted to see it
let's do it I would like to thank
everyone who commented on my time lapse
video for the mega magic ball.
The exact time that it took me to make was: 2 hours 13 minutes and 39 seconds and only one
person out of over 500 comments not the
exact hour and minute, which is really
impressive, and it was user 'Walee-Does"
So congratulations great job dude!  Also
the highest rated comment from my secret
subtitle was by "Justin". I will show some
other gueses that were really close
and some of my other choice comments
later on.   Be sure to look out for some
secret subtitles and comment for your
chance to be featured.
Also, don't forget to rate, share and
SUBSCRIBE and click that Notification
Bell if you do enjoy it!  Although there
are ways to make the Mini Magic Balls
without tape, it's a lot more challenging
and I'd like to show you the easiest way
I know first. I'm going to
a single sheet of 8.5 x 11"
printer paper but if you want to use an
11'' by 17'' sheet just like this or even
tape two pieces of origami paper
together that's fine also.
So grab your sheet of paper and let's go!
To turn your paper into 1 to 2 (1:2)
proportion rectangle like this with two
connected squares, first fold it in half, lining up the edges perfectly.
and making nice sharp creases set the
paper so that the vertical fold is a
mountain fold and then fold the corners
into the vertical midline like this and
then we could tear off the excess paper
on the bottom. Now that you have a paper
like this we're gonna flip it over and
fold these top two corners down to the
bottom also. Once again, making a nice
crease along the outside and do the same
with the upper left corner. Your paper
should now be twice as long as it is
wide with each square having an X in it.
Now your paper will be divided
in half along this vertical middle line
that is a mountain fold, also having two
X's on each side that I have marked with
dots (.) because this side is going to be
the outside or color side of the magic
ball.  The next thing we're going to do is
to split the paper into 16 vertical
sections just like this so let's go
ahead and do that. Take one end of the
paper and fold it on this vertical line
just like this across and then we're
going to hold it like this so that's the
two edges that are open are on the top
and take the top edge and fold
it down all the way to the bottom--again line it up as neatly as possible
and then make a crease along the top, running your
fingernail against it. Flip it over and
do the same exact thing: fold the top
edge down and crease sharply. Now when
you open up the paper you see we split
the paper into quarters and we're going
to take these two folds now and fold
them directly into the middle so just
pinch that fold on the right side and
just slide it right into the middle line
and make a crease here all the way
throughout the paper and if you lift up
the outside right edge you'll see we
created a new fold here and let's do the
same with the left side: slide the edge
directly into the middle and crease all
the way down the paper. Now, your paper
will look something like this
and we're going to take the outside
edges and also fold them directly into
the middle. Just take the edges one at
a time and fold them directly to the
midline just like this *sings-do-do-do-do-do* Now you'll
see we split the paper into eight
vertical sections. As you'll see the
paper now has three Mountain folds and
four valley folds, we're going to rotate
the paper and fold downwards on the
valley folds. Crease downwards on all
of the valley folds across the paper
just like this. Once you've done that,
open the paper once more and turn it 90
degrees like this and take this first
mountain fold and slide it directly to
the middle line--just pinch the mountain
fold like this and slide it down and
once it's lined up then make a crease
directly in the middle of this next
section here all the way across. That
basically creases the section in half as
you could see under here. Then we could
take the next section and split it in
half by taking this mountain fold and
doing the same thing; so just take that
next mountain fold and fold it down
right on top of the previous one we just
put in the middle, then let's flatten the
paper out.
Then let's just keep doing that: fold this one in, just like this, and then finally fold the
very last edge into the middle trying to
be as neat as possible
Now when you unfold everything you'll
see half of the paper is in sixteenths (1/16)
and now we could rotate the paper and do
the same thing with the other half just
like before take the mountain folds and
continue to bring them in to the middle
just like this take the last one and
just bring it down and then once you're
done with that we could take the outside
edge and finally fold it into the middle
once again give it a nice sharp crease.
Now we've split the paper into 16
vertical sections. Eventually, we will be
turning the vertical folds into mountain
folds. Now that we've divided it
vertically we can split it into eight
horizontal sections. First, we're going to
flip it on to the other side that's not
the "color side" just like this and just
flatten everything out. Then take the top
edge and fold it down to the bottom edge
and once they're aligned, we can crease (*Sound Effect*)
along that new top fold then we can just
crease the paper and open it up and
we're going to take the top and the
bottom edges and fold it directly onto
the horizontal midline just like this.
When you do that, just make sure that
each of the lines here lines up with the
rest of the fold. (*Sound Effects*)
Flip it upside down and then do the same
with the top, and as you'll see that line
that I drew is matching up with the
other side. You can unfold the paper and
flip it back over so that you have
something that looks just like this. All
horizontal creases are now Mountain
folds. Here is the horizontal middle line
and again we're going to take the first
Mountain fold here and fold it directly
in here by pinching it and sliding it
down directly into the middle and then
make a crease all the way across. Take
the outside edge and fold it down into
the middle also--taking your time and
being as neat as possible and lining up
all the creases. So fold it down, line it
up, and make a crease and now you flip it
around and do the same exact thing: Bring
the mountain fold directly into the
middle and flatten it out and then do
the same with the outside edge so if you
did that you should see an X with a
little bit of a box in the middle.  So now
again just run your fingernail against
the top and then we're basically just
going to fold the whole thing in half
just like this, so that it's kind of like a
fan. when you open up the paper you'll
see that we've split it into eight
different horizontal sections and 16
different vertical sections. To make the
next step easier we're going to make
each of those vertical folds into
mountain folds so just take the paper
like this and fold it on each of these
creases just like that downwards to make
sure they're each Mountain folds. So just
keep folding down and creasing on each
one of the 16 sections to make sure that
it has a nice crease. To finish the pre
creases we need to make X's in every
single one of the boxes that we have on
the paper I'm also going to draw some
boxes just to make things easier for you
to see *Draws on Creases*
To turn this into this we need to
make all of the diagonal PRE-creases
going this way.and then all of the ones
going this way. I'm just going to draw
dots here so that it can help you
visualize what you need to be looking at
when you're making those creases. *Draws dots on intersections*
So as you'll see I drew dots at each of the
intersections going this way and all the
intersections going this way. What
you're going to first do is to take the
corner here and fold it to this dot. Then
you're going to take it and go to this
side this dot, this dot... all the way
through. We're going to do the same going this way.
Start by taking the corner and
folding it into the first dot so that
this edge and this edge are aligned with with this one and this one, respectively.
When you
do that, just make a nice sharp crease
and as you'll see not only are this edge
and this edge lined up with those two
lines that we drew, but this diagonal
line she'll also be in line with the one
that we have here. Then you can open it
up and then fold it into the second one--
make a nice sharp crease. At this point,
you'll see that this horizontal line
should be in line with this one and this
one should be in line with this one... so
there's just a couple of things that you
need to see when you do that just to
make sure everything is lined up nice
and neat then you can open it and do the
next one so fold it in to the third one.
Then we can continue to fold the corner
down to each intersection until we get
down to the bottom here. Make sure
there's a nice crease on the fourth one.
Just make sure everything is lined up so
now let's speed it up a little bit..(*Speed Increases*) just
continue to fold the corner down to each
dot on the diagonal line until you get
down to the bottom when we get down to
the bottom, you'll see we've already made
this diagonal fold across so we just
need to put the corner down and flatten
it out. Then we could fold the bottom
left corner to each one of these points
on this diagonal line. I just like to
flip the paper over because it's easier
for me, but you can do it whichever way
you like. Fold the corner to each
intersection of the boxes that I marked.
Be as neat as possible, lining up the
grid and making nice sharp creases.
Now, you should have something that looks
like this, however we have not finished
all the pre creases that go in this
direction. You've only done up to here
--the corners-- so we just need to do the
seven (7) remaining ones in the middle so
I'll draw on the ones that we've already
done so you can see. At this point once
your paper looks like mine, you'll see
that we've done the creases all the way
down to the corners. So like I said we
just need to do the seven remaining ones
directly in the middle. If you look
closely, you'll see that this edge folds
directly on to the midline so all we
need to do is to shift the edge directly
to the left on this next vertical line.
So just shift that edge to the next or
adjacent vertical line and then we can
make a crease on the outside. Again,
following the same guidelines that these
horizontal lines are continuous with the
rest of the horizontal line on
left side of the paper. At this point
you'll notice that you have one row
that's overhanging on the bottom with
this line coinciding with the very
bottom edge of the paper.
Once you have it lined up like that, just
make a nice sharp crease all the way
throughout and crease it with your
fingernail. So, it's going to go to the
next one over: now you have two rows on
the bottom the second line here should
coincide with the bottom-- so make sure
all those lines are basically lined up
If you look at the bottom very closely,
you'll see that these diagonal folds
should coincide with the ones that are
already on this part of the paper as you
can see right here (*line*) so now we can crease
it and you'll see at the bottom we have
two rows hanging off. Then we can
continue to shift the edge over until
there's four overhanging rows. So just so
you can see, I'm going to draw on the
last four that we just did *Draws* and continue
to fold to these points now. Turn it over
like this and once again we're going to
take this corner and fold it all the way
down to the bottom of the paper. Since we
did four on this side, we know that we
have three (3) more left to do because there are only seven (7) in between the ones from
corner to corner.  So, we just have to
basically get it down to here so we just
need through it three more times: there's
one,  there's two,  and three and there you
go you finished all the diagonal folds
going this way and again I'll draw on it
so that you could see which ones we've
done. So now you'll see we've done all of
the diagonal folds that are going in
this direction.  A good way to check to
see if you miss any fold is to look on
the back because Mountain folds are a
lot easier to see than Valley folds.  At
this point, you should have a piece of
paper that looks like this with all of
the diagonal pre creases in this
direction completed. We're now going to
do the diagonal pre creases in this (opposite)
direction by taking these corners and
folding them inwards this way. Once we
get to the midline here, or at this point
here. We're then going to do the same
thing that we did in the other direction.
So let's go ahead and do that. Just like
in the other direction: fold the corner
to each one of the dots on the line
intersections. All the horizontal and
vertical folds should meet up--keep
folding until the corner reaches the
very bottom of the paper. Now I'm going
to flip it over and do the same with this corner.
Once again, folding the corner down to each one of the intersections and aligning
the edges and folds. So now I will draw on
the pre creases that we just made: we now
have seven more pre-creases to make in
this direction. So just like before I'm
going to put the corner down and shift
it over to each one of these points,
again making sure that all of the
creases align and that I have four rows
overhanging on the bottom. Once again, now that there's four overhanging rows on
this side, we could flip it over and then
we're going to fold this corner down so
that there's three overhanging rows. (*3,2,1!!)
Great job! We just did all the PRE-
creases and every box should have an
"X"in it! So, as you'll see I have a grid
of 8 boxes by 16 boxes (8x16=?) and every single
one has an X in it. It's quite easy to
see this when you flip it over as well.
You need to be very familiar with the
Water Bomb and that the diagonal folds in
it are very sharp VALLEY folds. We're also
going to be dealing with something I
call the "Double Airplane Base" that looks
something like this and they're going to
be connected in this fashion. In this
larger scale you can see how the two
bases connect and that they'll flatten out and connect like so
You're going to have to be very familiar with this
pattern that has a waterbomb followed by
a double airplane base then next to
another water bomb that's connected to a
double airplane base.  In the columns
you'll see that the water bombs are
actually connected to each other there
are also staggered or offset which
creates a zigzag pattern. If you follow
along and pay close attention, with some
practice you'll definitely get it!
Although the lines I drew on the paper
show all the pre creases that we now
folded, not EVERY fold is necessary to
collapse the ball. So to avoid confusion
I outlined on this sheet the folds that
we will need to collapse to make the
magic ball. *Remember* this side I am
holding UP will be the Outside or the
Color side of the magic ball. It's up to
you but you may want to go over the
diagonal creases in both directions and
also the mountain folds just because
it'll make it a little bit easier to
collapse the model. We're going to fan
out the model by first folding upwards
by Valley folding in the first crease
and then mountain folding and all
alternating all the way till you get
down to the bottom. When you look at it
from the side you'll see that you have
four V's (VVVV) connected to each other with
alternating Valley folds and mountain
folds. We will start working on the Mini
Magic Ball layer to layer, first creating
a Water Bomb in the upper right portion
of the paper. We need to complete the top
layer and to do that we need to reverse
fold or tuck in this upper right
valley-fold here like this and then
squeeze these two edges together. With
really sharp pre-creases this shouldn't
be too challenging. Directly next to it
will be a double airplane base as you
can see here. So, we basically just open
up these two edges and we're going to
push downwards on this horizontal fold
just like this-- when you do that you'll
see that these two corners will fold
upwards towards this mountain fold and
then you could just pinch it just like that
Again next to the double airplane fold will be another
water bomb base so
you can just kind of tuck this in like
this and just give it a nice squeeze
like this again we're going to have
another double airplane base so just
open it up like this and just push
downwards here. It's also good to have a
feeling for where your finger is on the
back of the model like right here so
that you can also push from the back
just like that you can just push
downward and do the same thing. Fold
upwards on this corner and fold upwards
on this corner you'll see when you
flatten everything out you have
basically completed the first layer of
the magic ball. Looking at it from the
front view like this you'll notice that
we have a half a waterbomb, the airplane
folds here, another half of a waterbomb
and the airplane fold. You'll also notice
that there are four distinct sections in
the paper.  With the section below the
airplane base being kind of lifted up
and the section below this top portion
of the water bomb collapsed into a
valley fold and you'll also see that it
looks like a Y. The same thing with this
airplane and this half water bomb that
we have here. On the bottom you can more
easily see the Y which have Mountain
folds below them while beneath the
airplane folds are sort of boxed out
like this. Now that you understand the
basics let's move on. Here again is the
double airplane base so we're just going
to squeeze it and also tuck this corner
in
like this. We have a "Y" here and the "Y's
are going to turn into X's or waterbomb
bases. To do this we're just going to
open it up like this and push from
behind on this horizontal crease like
this, give it a little squeeze and then
you can kind of collapse it like that.
Then again we're going to work on the
next water bomb here the Y. To do that
we're going to lift it up just like this
and give it a nice squeeze. You'll see
that we have an X a Y and X and a Y. If
you flip it over a good thing to do is
to take your finger and just basically
follow it up to the end of the Y to make
sure that these creases are nice and
sharp. So if it's popped out just make
sure that it's like this and then just
walk your finger all the way up. Now when
you flip it over you'll see again we
have an X Y X Y and we're going to start
from the left side now this Y is going
to turn into an X so just open up these
two edges
Pinch it here and then you can collapse
it so we're basically alternating
between the first and third Y's to turn
into X's and the second and fourth Y's
to turn into X's since we did the first
one here let's do the third one. Open it
up lift it up from behind and then
squish it. Now we're going to be working
on the second and fourth one. Just lift
it up like this and give it a pinch. Then
again we're going to do the second one
so just open up these two edges here
push from behind give it a little pinch
here and then basically collapse the
model just like this. Now we're going to
be working on the first and the third
one so again this is also the double
airplane base so we're going to tuck
this in just like that. Then we're
going to turn it into a waterbomb base
so just lift it up from behind and just
squish it like that. Then we're going to
turn this one here into a waterbomb base
as well by squishing it down like that
Now we're going to turn this one into a
waterbomb base and then we're going to
turn the one in the second row into a
waterbomb base. I'm going to speed up a
little bit because it is the same
process but I will slow down when we get
to the end because it is a little
trickier. (*Speed Up*) Continuing on we're going to
this why into an X by pushing from the
back just like this and then collapsing
it. Now going to section three by pushing
also on the back and squishing it down
turn this Y into X the same way and then
on section two squish it down.
Now we're going to turn this Y into an X the same
way. As you'll see, it doesn't want to
fold that way so just take your
fingernail and run it along the X and
that should allow you to squish it down
by pushing it down like that. Now, let's
go on to section three by pulling it
apart and collapsing it just like that. As
you'll see, this one here it doesn't want
to fold all the way on this diagonal so
again like I said before just flip it
over and all you need to do is to take
your hand and walk it up on this Mountain
fold all the way up to the bottom of the
Y and that will basically make nice
creases and you could do that every time
if you want in order to make sure that
it folds in the proper creases. Just
compress the model again and you'll
notice that we have the X Y X Y so we're
just going to do the same thing and
collapse this fourth one and then the
second one then once again we're gonna
do the first one by tucking that in and
collapsing it just like this and then
doing the third one. Pinch it and
collapse it. Then, we can once again do
the second and fourth ones so here we're
just going to push on the back here and
collapse it and then again do the second
one by opening the edges and squishing
it down. Then once again collapse it and
move on. Do the same thing by compressing
each of these Y's into X's until we get
to this part here and now I'll go
through how to finish collapsing the
Mini Magic Ball! We're almost done
collapsing the mini magic ball, and at
this point it makes it easier if you
kind of hold it like this by basically
grabbing it on these water bombs on the
bottom here. What we're going to do
is the same thing: we're going to turn
this Y here into an X by lifting up on
this crease here like this and just
collapsing it then again just kind of
hold it like this
and you'll see we have another Y right
here so just push up right on this
little crease just like that
to open it a little bit more if it gets
stuck and then you can kind of crease it
down now again see how it got stuck well
that's because it's not creasing the way
it's supposed to.. remember it needs to
fold on these diagonals so just push
right here and you'll see that will kind
of turn into a Y just like that okay and
then we could basically just kind of
hold it and push it together just like
this now the last ones that we need to
do well remember the Y's need to turn
into X's or water bombs and then here
are going to be the airplane folds so
let's start with the right side we're
going to turn this into a water bomb to
do that this corner here needs to get
folded up like that. What we're going to
do is just take it and fold it up like
this and that will not only finish the
water bomb but it will also create the
double airplane base. Now, we're
going to create another double airplane
base here by taking this corner and
folding it up as well all right and then
we're going to do the same here by
taking this and folding it up and that
will create the water bomb here so we
have the water bomb and then the double
airplane base and then finally we're
going to take this corner and fold it up
and now you've completed collapsing the
mini magic ball! Now that we've finished
collapsing the magic ball, we need to
change it into something that looks like
this and then finally into this so that
we can connect it together and finish
the magic ball the first step will be to
undo or untuck these edges or inside
reverse folds. I included them in the
collapsing process because it makes it
easier to visualize the water bombs so
hold the magic ball just like this with
the water bomb here in the upper right
and what we're going to do is just
untuck it here and flatten it down just
like that then continue down by
untucking and flattening it like this
untuck and flatten and then keep going (*Music Jazz*)
If you open it you'll see this side of
the model should basically look like
there's eight V's connected to one
another just like that now we're going
to flip it around and we're going to do
the same thing with this corner we're
just going to untuck it or unfold it
like this and then we're going to untuck
these edges or inside reverse folds as
well so just the same thing untuck it
like this and flatten it out and then
just do the rest (*Music*)
Finally just unfold this corner that
we had folded in so on this side you
should see that it's basically eight
mountain folds that are connected to
each other one side will start and end
with Mountain folds with the other side
starting and ending with Valley folds
like this. To turn this into this we need
to reverse fold each one of these
mountain folds and fold this corner down
just like this, so let's go ahead and do
that. Hold it with the side starting with
the valley folds and we're going to take
this corner and fold it down now we're
going to reverse fold this mountain fold
by just taking it and pushing downwards
along this line and this crease here now
it's not already creased that way so you
kind of have to force it,  just a
little bit. Do the same with the
remaining mountain folds by tucking them
in and pinching them so it looks
something like this and continue all the
way down by doing the same thing
completing the reverse folds and then
again when you get to the end here just
take this corner and fold it down like
this once you fold that corner down and
collapse it it should look something
like this now that we folded down the
corners and reverse fold at each one of
these edges we're going to do the same
on the other side it's a little
different because we just have Mountain
folds here so all we need to do is to
reverse fold each one of these edges in
so let's go ahead and do that: tuck it in
and pinch (*Music*)
And now you're done with all of the
folds for the mini magic ball (YaYYYYYYYYY!) Now that
you reverse folded did all the edges and
folded down the corners on the other
side you should be able to compress the
model just like this before we join the
two edges of the magic ball together
like this just make sure that all the
creases are nice and sharp and that
nothing is stuck. If you have something
like this where it's kind of stuck then
you want to just correct it by just
putting your finger in here and then
giving it a little bit of a pinch
alright guys congratulations you've done
all of the precreasing and collapsing so
now you're all done you finished the
origami peacock tail and the origami fan
also the origami barbells!
Alright, so seriously all we need to do
now is to basically tape the two ends
together if you'll look at it you'll see
that it is symmetrical, so when you join
the two ends together it will meet up
and you'll be able to stick them
together like that. All we need to do is
to kind of pick one and it doesn't
really matter at this point so just take
the corner here and the other corner and
we're going to gently pull them apart
like this and we're going to try to
flatten it out. Now, don't get a little
worried here because I know we did work
hard on the collapsing part it will
re-collapse on it. You're going to memorize
what it looks like of course and also
squeeze it really hard like this so that
the memory is in the paper and press it
down and squeeze really hard. Then you
could open up the end like this and the
other end and just gently pull on them
like that and we're just going to
flatten it out by just pressing on any
of these folds that are kind of sticking up, like that.
Then we can do that with the other side
so just take it just kind of pull it
apart and just press gently on any of
these folds like this and just kind of
get that edge nice and flat like this.
Then we're going to take the tape and
just take it off the Roll like this and
we're going to take it and put it on the
inside of the mini magic ball on this
side here. As you'll see the tape is
about the width of one of the boxes so
we're actually just gonna put it halfway
because we are going to join the two
ends together. So just leave a little bit
overhanging and stick it about half-way
on this box here like that. Once it's
half-way and lined up parallel like this
then you can kind of stick it on and
just gently pull off the rest of the
tape just walk it down like this on the
edge. Then you could rip off the end of
the tape like this and then we're just
going to gently press down on this so
it's kind of folded back in that round
shape and just do the same with the
other edge like this so just still flat
but just folded downward. Now we could join
the two edges together. We're gonna take
the corner and just make sure it is
press downwards here as you see it came
apart so we're going to stick it like
this, make sure it's nice and flat here
as you'll see the memory will still kind
of be in the paper and just remember
what the creases are in the paper so
again this is the double airplane base
then we can take the two ends and we're
just going to take the corners here, it
doesn't matter which end you use, just
start with one of them and join up the
two ends on the tape like this. Press the
corners together and just gently walk
your finger down on the edge.  Just join up
the rest of the folds and the edges like
this and just gently press down until
you're about halfway like that. Then you
could take the other corner and put it
on top of the other edge like this and
join up the corners and just gently
press on it like this again we are going
to be pressing on the inside here so
just press and just make sure that
everything has kind of touched the tape
and as you'll see it will start
collapsing in the way it should but some
of it might get stuck. Just keep working on
it giving it a nice press on the tape
just like this and making sure all
points are touching. You can kind of fold
this excess tape on the other side what
we have here is we have a little house
and if you kind of turn it like this
you'll see the Y is still here and it's
all in Valley Folds so that's what we're
going to have here we're gonna have a
little Y in Valley folds like this and
then this edge here is going to be
inside reverse fold to make a little
point and then you can kind of pinch
that point together just do that for the
rest of the top of the paper here. So
another inside reverse fold and upside
down Y and then you could pinch these
edges together
It's gonna be a little harder on the tape but
you'll eventually get it. Any area where
you're gonna have this X here you're
just gonna push in the middle like that
and that will kind of collapse the
waterbomb again again here on the X
we're just going to press here and that
will allow it to collapse and press
gently like this again here on the top
we have the house and has upside-down Y
in valley-fold so again next to here is
gonna have an upside-down Y which it
does already. Then there's gonna be
an inside reverse fold here. Pinch the
two edges together and as you'll see
it's kind of coming together again here
we're just gonna have the upside down
house with the Y so this is going to be
inside reverse folded like this and the
house is going to come together like
that just make sure these edges are
touching on the tape then you can inside
reverse fold this part if the edges
become unstuck then press them harder to
the tape in order to better adhere them
just make sure all the creases is going
the way that they need and you'll
eventually be able to kind of collapse
it like this you should see eight points
here from these little houses on the top
and also the bottom and all of the water
bombs should again be formed and here's
where the tape is you can kind of just
give it a nice squeeze like this to make
sure the edges are touching on the tape
like that and there you go it's all
collapsed and all we need to do is to
break it in now.
To break in the Mini Magic Ball, I first like to collapse it, pressing
and squishing it back and forth just
like this. Then I like to push on top
until it turns inside out you'll notice
when you do that it flattens and forms a
lip or ridge on the top. Then you can
transform it into an eight-pointed star
just like this with a smaller eight
pointed star inside you need to crease
these outside points by pinching them
one at a time.
Once you have the flower shape you can
then stretch it by pulling on outside
points. To open or inflate the ball again
you need to pull up and out on the
outside of the opposite inside points to
reinflate the ball. At this point we
need to fix any folds which may have
been collapsed, unfolded or crushed and
then we could squish or collapse back
together like we did when we first
connected it at the ends. Once it's
broken in then you could try turning it
inside out just like this but be careful
not to rip it. And there you go you have
finished your Mini Magic Ball!
Amber Rooster and Ava21 both guessed 2 hours 10 minutes
Props to Aman for guessing the exact time on my watch
Chicken Nuggs, Applegamer08 and Julien all got to fifteen
while Edwin Bello got two hours and
seventeen
Here are the comments I picked
and the secret subtitles
Sir, we may have a possible hostile
intruder in Sector Rob's World
Commander Can you get a lock on it?
Locked On! Intel says it's made
of paper!
Sorry Sir, we've lost it.  Comment: "Turn on subtitles" if you see this.